well I hope you're all having a blessed
good Friday I do say blessed Good Friday
not happy Good Friday
I cringe a little bit when someone says
happy Good Friday although they mean
well I suppose it's but today is more of
a somber remembrance than a happy
occasion and it's it's a day that for me
brings to mind my favorite story the
gospel which is as I think I've shared
before which is the one of the penitent
thief on the cross it's just it's a
small little tidbit three of the Gospels
don't even think to mention it but but
Luke does and I've always found it to be
especially powerful because it's this
image of repentance on the cross you
know moments before death and the way
that the penitent thief is assured of
right then and there of his salvation
you just imagine the joy that he must
have felt and I think it's a great story
so I hope that we all take some time to
read and reflect on the entire passion
narrative today on Good Friday now
there's a lot to cover I'm not gonna
harp much on the Moller report today I
think all that all that needs to be said
about it has already been said and will
continue being said of course ad nauseam
for the next two years really so we know
that Trump did not collude he's not
being charged with obstruction either he
is he is guilty of being reckless and
dishonest as the report does show but
all that is baked into the cake at this
point I think that's something that
maybe some people still don't understand
is is that you know we anyone who's been
paying even a little bit of attention
over the last two or three years knows
what Trump is all about and we've taken
that into account we factored it in one
way or another so the political damage
will be minimal here I think but as we
discussed yesterday the goal posts are
being routed out of the ground and
dragged across the field now whereas
before it was all about collusion now
it's not about collusion anymore because
Trump has been vindicated on the
collusion score and
and notice how you know no one is really
arguing about that now they're arguing
about obstruction and it should there be
impeachment they're using those words so
you're gonna hear you know the word
collusion has fallen out of the media's
lexicon and instead what we're hearing
is obstruction and impeachment but it's
really interesting that nobody's even
bothering to dispute the collusion thing
because Trump was so thoroughly absolved
on that score
that even his enemies are not even
trying to claim anymore that he was
colluding if anyone but instead they're
saying no he obstructed so for example
we pull up the where to go the
Washington Post's front page of their
print edition which honestly I'm shocked
that physical newspapers even still
exist but they do and so this is what
they're if you if you went for some
reason and bought a Washington Post at
the 7-eleven this these are all of the
headlines on their front page okay
notice what word is missing so the big
big headline is molar details Russian
interference Trump's attempt to disrupt
probe that was a big headline and then
other headlines on the page says again
and again president's aides refused to
carry out his orders question of
obstruction seemingly tossed to Congress
frame it however you like but it's a
damning portrait of Trump's presidency
these are all headlines on the page
Trump's efforts to obstruct we're clear
Democrats say but impeachment isn't
offers from Russia were not reported or
forcefully rejected by campaign okay so
those are all the headlines that the
Washington Post offers you notice what
word is missing
collusion there's there's no mention
inclusion it they don't even think to
mention in any of the articles on the
front pages oh by the way he actually
was not colluding with Russia he was not
a secret Russian agent it turns out this
is the way it's gonna go the media is at
war with the president has been since
the beginning of his term of course but
that war has now entered a new phase if
you thought that it are
it had already gotten as ugly as it was
going to get you're mistaken because
it's gonna get a lot worse
and you know what they just might
salvage this thing for the president I
think this is probably good news for
Trump the media against all odds might
salvage 2024 the for Trump I think all
things being equal okay Trump faces the
very real possibility of not just losing
in 2020 but of a landslide historic and
historically embarrassing loss he does
face that possibility and it's just
there's just no denying him he and I'll
tell you why because he won in 2016 with
three million fewer votes than than
Hillary and the reason why that happened
was because Hillary ignored the Rust
Belt so there was that she didn't she
didn't focus on those states like
Michigan Wisconsin Pennsylvania and the
urban voters in those states did not
show up they didn't show up in great
numbers in Philly and in Detroit which
is that's how Democrats win you know
Pennsylvania and Michigan is by is by
getting the turnout in those those
cities and the reason that those voters
in show up and why you know a lot of
Hillary's voters did show up four is
because number one they weren't excited
about her because she's Hillary Clinton
and number two because few people took
Trump seriously and they figured I was
gonna lose anyway you know I don't need
to go vote in 2020 Trump is not going to
have those advantages anymore he will
not be running against Hillary
unfortunately and the Democratic base
will show up absolutely they will show
up in force because they hate shrubs and
guts and it really doesn't even matter
now I mean he could actually run against
Hillary again and I think this time it
would be completely different because it
almost doesn't matter who they put up
against him their voters are gonna show
up in master they'll have their biggest
turnout ever for sure
no question
so what that means is that Trump cannot
win if he simply has maintained the same
voters he certainly can't if he's lost
any voters then he can't he's doomed he
needs to have not only maintain he needs
to have gained a whole bunch of new
voters to win again and then we have to
ask the question has he really done
anything in office to attract new
legions of supporters I know that if you
if you're a die-hard supporter then
you're still a die-hard supporter great
that's that's that's good but you might
not be a good judge of this because
you're if your support of the president
has maybe clouded your ability to look
at it objectively a little bit because
the fact is while maybe you love the
things that he's done in office and the
way that he's generally carried himself
I don't think it has necessarily
attracted new people okay so at a
minimum he's I think he's kind of
flatlined as far as that goes but he's
probably lost people as well which is
bad news but the point is the media may
pull this out for him again like they
did in 2016
they might just do it because the one
thing that could manage to actually give
Trump a bigger turnout than he got in
2016 would be people just completely
disgusted with the media and with the
left and so they're turning out in masse
against that group it's possible now III
think that that's Trump's best hope at
this point and with the way that the
media has I mean the way with the way
it's conducted itself over the last two
years but especially now this with this
Muller thing they're they're just being
so blatantly dishonest and if they
continue with that and maybe if the
Democrats move forward with impeachment
trying to impeach even though there was
no underlying crime well maybe they'll
alienate just enough people to put put
Trump over the top so you know I guess I
guess our message to them is continue
right along you know continue continue
with as you were basically all right now
let's turn to an absolutely horrific
story out of Bangladesh I'm going to
read a part of the report from the BBC
reported by mere Sabir and here's what
it says this is a just a terrible story
trying to pull up okay it says Nusrat
Jahan Rafi was doused with kerosene and
set on fire at her school in Bangladesh
less than two weeks earlier she had
filed a sexual-harassment camp complaint
against her headmaster her courage in
speaking out against sexual assault her
death five days after being set alight
and everything that happened in between
his gripped Bangladesh and brought
attention to the vulnerability of sexual
harassment victims in this conservative
South Asian country
Nusrat who was 19 was from a small town
100 miles south of Dakar
she was studying at a madrasah or
Islamic school on the 27th of March she
said that the headmaster called her into
his office and repeatedly touched her in
an inappropriate manner before things
could go any further she ran out and it
goes on a little bit later says at the
local police station she gave a
statement she should have been provided
with a safe environment to recall her
traumatic experience and experiences
instead she was filmed by the officer in
charge on his phone and as she described
the ordeal so the officer was was
filming her in the video
Nusrat is visibly distressed and tries
to hide her face with her hands the
policeman is heard calling the complaint
no big deal and telling her to move her
hands from her face that video was later
leaked to the media
so this scumbag guy made sure to get her
face on camera and then immediately sent
it to the media
then after she went to the police they
arrested the headmaster but then things
got worse for Nusrat a group of people
gathered in the streets demanding his
release the protests had been arranged
by two male students and local
politicians were allegedly in attendance
people get began to blame the the woman
her family say that she started to worry
about her safety then she went back to
school regardless of this fearing for
safety she still went to school because
she wanted to finish her final exams
according to a statement given by an
Estrada fellow female student took her
to the roof of the school saying one of
her friends was being beaten up when
Nusrat reached the rooftop four or five
people wearing burkas surrounded her and
allegedly pressured her to withdraw the
case against the headmaster when she
when she refused they set her on fire
then it goes on from there in the
ambulance fearing that she might not
survive she recorded a statement on her
brother's mobile phone she said they the
teacher touched me I will fight this
crime till my last breath and then
eventually she dies ok so the first
thing that jumps out of the out at you
about this story is the incredible
courage of this young woman I mean she
obviously knew the risks involved in
reporting the contact conduct of her
alleged abuser when you think about how
hesitant you know we can be even in this
country to report inappropriate conduct
by people who are in authority over us
not just sexual misconduct but any kind
of misconduct you think about how
hesitant we can be because of the
consequences we might face well the
risks that she faced were a hundred
times greater than anything we faced and
yet she did it anyway so that is
extremely heroic and then even as she
was dying after being set on fire she
still was standing her ground and
demanding justice I mean you just don't
encounter this kind of courage every day
the second thing is we have to realize
that in fundamentalist Islamic countries
this is what women face
they're not only required to
walk around in bags essentially covered
from head to toe but if they're raped or
abused they can be punished for it
they can be set on fire or stoned to
death or attacked and some other equally
gruesome way and and this is why it's so
dangerous I think to engage in the sort
of cultural relativism where we say oh
well all you know all cultures are equal
we can't judge you know everything is it
so it's all equal this is why it's
dangerous to condemn people who
celebrate Western culture as objectively
superior to other cultures on which it
is and our Western culture is superior
to the culture that that this woman
lived in it's dangerous because when you
do that when you do this relativistic
thing when you insist that even even
this culture where this happened is
equal to our own you are denying or
downplaying or dismissing the horrific
treatment suffered by women and and and
homosexuals and many other groups in
these countries what you're saying is
yeah it's not cool but you know it's not
so bad I mean it's not it's not so bad
that we should make any statements about
the overall culture but we should we
should there is something deeply
disordered about a culture where women
are treated like this where a woman is
not even allowed to show her face in
public for fear of being killed I mean
there's something deeply wrong there the
point is when we say that Western
civilization is better than the cultures
that essentially enslave women we are
not saying that the individual human
beings themselves are better okay it's
not what we're saying we are saying that
our system of treating women with
respect and dignity is better we're
saying that that's a better way and
that's what we should be saying
we should be putting that forward as an
objectively better system and and saying
you know this is a better way to be so
you just you can't have it both ways
you really can't you cannot claim that
you are you know fighting for equality
for women across the globe and then in
the next breath say that well you know
cultures that treat women like cattle
are equal to ours and we can't make any
judgments no in our culture you know
Western civilization is not perfect
America is not perfect by any means and
I'll be the first one to say that listen
through abortion we've we have killed 60
million babies through abortion and so
that is a historic atrocity that is
certainly holding us back
morally from being the kind of moral
light to the world that we could
otherwise be so there are there are
serious problems in our own civilization
and interestingly enough most of the
people who engage in this cultural
relativism who say that you know hey are
we're not much better than them they're
the same ones who defend this this
atrocity
that is proved that is preventing us
from being that moral light so we have
our own issues but the fact is in this
country you know despite what feminists
say I mean women are free in this
country and they can walk around in
public and they can get jobs and they
can live lives just like any man can and
you're not going to hear stories like
this in America
so we you know it's easy enough to say
that well we condemn this particular
incident of course everyone would say
that right but we also need to condemn
the aspects of that culture that allow
this sort of thing to happen let's see
here
a couple other things I wanted to
mention something on a much lighter note
a guy posted a picture of his son's math
test to Facebook a couple of days ago
and his son is in second grade he was he
wanted to call attention to the some of
the comments that the teacher made on
his second grade son's math test okay so
this is this is why there's the image of
the test and what the teacher allegedly
wrote now we have the image that he put
on Facebook well the teacher on this
image the the comment says absolutely
pathetic
he answered thirteen and three minutes
sad with a song with a smiley face first
of all I wouldn't take this at face
value
maybe it's legitimate but that by no
means is established and just because
you see a picture of something on the
internet doesn't mean that it's true I
think hopefully by now we all understand
that so it might be a hoax or something
like that but if it isn't I mean is it
wrong of me to laugh at this it may be
maybe this pathetic maybe this is the
kind of feedback that our kids need
toughen them up a bit it's a dog-eat-dog
world out there and I don't know there
might not be anything wrong with that I
said that's all I'm saying okay finally
Netflix launched into a hectoring tweet
storm a couple of days ago complaining
about the phrase chick flick and I want
to share this with you for a couple of
reasons but first of all because you see
here
stark contrasts between the sorts of
things that feminists are worried about
in this country versus what what women
face in other other parts of the world
and you start to think you know maybe
this feminist should be less concerned
about this sort of thing and should be
spending I don't know all of their time
and efforts calling attention to women
who are being set on fire and killed for
being sexually assaulted in other parts
of the world but in this country this is
what they're worried about so this is
what this is what Netflix said in their
feminist screed they said for starters
chick flicks are traditionally so
Nominet synonymous with romantic
comedies this suggests that women are
the only people interested in one
romance and to comedy which I can
promise from the men I've come across in
my life simply isn't true
these aren't sweeping categories
specific to men you don't hear people
asking to watch man movies instead
pretty much every intersection of genre
is on the table and in scene as for men
except of course the after mentioned
rom-coms
the term also cheapens the work that
goes into making these types of films
romantic comedies and/or film centered
around female leads go through just as
much editing consideration and rewriting
as any other film and nicknaming films
chick flicks drives home that there's
something trivial about watching them
but what's trivial about watching a film
that makes you feel a thousand emotions
in 90 minutes overall there's nothing
inherently gendered about liking a
light-hearted film with a strong female
lead and emotional arc so next time you
call something a chick flick
you better be referring to chicken run
okay so the first problem here is just
the triviality of it and this is what
feminists are worried about the second
thing is you do hear people talking
about man movies or movies for men and
I'm not offended by that as a man it
doesn't offend me but here's the thing
here's the double standard because okay
if we call something a chick flick or a
woman a movie for women that's offensive
to women apparently but if we were to
say of a Bruce Willis action movie that
it's a man movie that's offensive
to women so no matter what it's
offensive to women now how does that
work for a second so I thought if we
gender a movie and say it's only for a
particular gender then it is offensive
to the gender that we have assigned it
to but no that's not that's parently not
the case no matter what you do it's just
going to be offensive to women in the
end and that's that's that's the way it
works but of course in the end it
doesn't matter because it's just it's
it's still it's a light-hearted way of
referring to a movie it doesn't matter
and this really reminds me of this clip
that's making the rounds online right
now of brie Larson reacting to a
light-hearted joke that one over one of
her fellow cast mates made but watch
this thank you very much yeah and that's
what that's what feminism has become
can't even can't even take a joke yeah I
mean taking yourself way too seriously
I guess if we were to sum up feminism in
one kind of line or one phrase I think
that's sort of what it is it's women who
take themselves way too seriously and
have no sense of humor whatsoever all
right let's go to emails Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
this is from John it says Matt crucial
questions what's your favorite type of
beer ale lager
amber etc what's your favorite
mass-produced beer like Coors Sam Adams
etc what's your favorite craft brew it's
a fascinating inquiry here's how it
breaks down for me if I'm gonna sit down
and have only one beer which I mean why
would I have four to that of course it's
absurd obviously you'd have more than
one but in that case I'll probably go
with a porter that's my that's my go-to
you can't beat the richness and
complexity of a porter in my opinion but
I'm not gonna sit there and have three
Porter's it's a little bit too much so
if I'm going for higher volumes then
I'll go with an ale probably an IPA you
know
something like that so for me Ales
employers are number one best
mass-produced beer
well Miller Lite Budweiser that tastes
like watered-down goat urine and yes I
do know what that tastes like
so I would say best mass-produced
probably be Sam Adams or
Sierra Nevada Sierra Nevada prevalent
and then finally best craft brewery
that's a tough one because I think
they're all great I've never had I've
never encountered a craft brewery that
doesn't make good beer but I guess I got
to go with the og of craft breweries
that would be a dogfish head I don't
know his dogfish I do you really can't
beat can't beat them this from brian
says Matt I love your show but I
disagree with your assessment of Trump
as a quote reckless loudmouth I think he
says what's on his heart and I find that
refreshing well Brian I get that you
find it refreshing and you know I
respect that that's that's your opinion
your perspective that's fine but well
you have to understand is that the vast
majority of people don't feel that way
and I think there are also a lot of
people who used to feel that way and
don't anymore and I think that there's
probably nobody who you know really
didn't like that style but recently has
decided you know what that's that's
great I love it when Trump's constantly
running his mouth and you know just
saying whatever happens to pop into his
head
whether it's true or not whether it
makes sense or not whether it's relevant
or not whether it matters or not you
know I don't think there's anyone who
has recently decided they actually love
that I think there are a lot of people
who have in the last few years I've just
gotten sick of it and would like to see
maybe a little bit of presidential
behavior maybe just a little bit every
now and that every now and then so
that's my point that you know you might
personally like it and that's fine but
as a supporter of the president when you
encourage more of it you're not doing
yourself any favors you're not doing
Trump any favors you're not doing his
re-election chances any favors you're
just not I tell you
think about in the last
I mean really throughout his presidency
what are the moments when Trump seems to
you know really almost verge on the on
the edge of even getting some good press
and what are the Trump moments that you
can think of where at least pretty much
all conservatives seem to rally around
it and be energized by what when does
that happen it seems to happen well the
last example I can think of as a State
of the Union speech okay it seems like a
million years ago now but his State of
the Union speech was a great speech the
all conservatives seemed to be energized
by it and loved it and he was even even
got a little bit of credit outside of
the conservative circles for giving a
good speech
and I think any other example you can
name would be something like that where
he delivered a scripted speech and he
had what appeared to be a presidential
moment where he really seemed like a
president like a dignified kind of guy
up there in charge in command
it's those are the moments that appeal
to that appeal beyond Trump's hardcore
fans he never has moments like that
because of what he tweets or because of
one of his rambling pep rally speeches
that he gives that appeals to the people
who he doesn't need to appeal to because
they're on his side no matter what
his most hardcore fans I think to win in
2020 he needs fewer of those moments
where he is winning people who will vote
for him literally no matter what he says
or do does he needs fewer of those
moment he needs a lot more of the State
of the Union type moments and I think if
you're interested in him getting
reelected that's what you would be
encouraging let's see from Jesse says hi
Matt just want to let you know that your
show is definitely the worst on the
daily water you're not as thoughtful as
Ben or as funny as Knowles or as
entertaining as Clavin and your long
wandering rambles about theology and
biblical
and whatever other topic you feel like
babbling about are not interesting I
don't even say this to be mean I'm just
trying to be honest and I'm not in all
caps sending this so that you'll read it
on your show sorry about that I'm just
giving some honest feedback okay no I
mean I don't even care what you what you
think so
hold on put some water look what you've
done you've heard my feelings does it
look like I'm crying I can't get there
you know I really feel like I could I
was think about this the other day when
I was watching TV that I could be a
Hollywood actor I I think I could act
yeah I think almost anyone could it
doesn't seem like that hard except for
the fake crying thing I can't pull that
off I don't know how they do that when
you have got the scene where someone's
really emotionally distraught and you
know they're just the waterworks attack
that I could not do that's the that is
the one that's the most impressive
element of acting in my opinion let's
see here we'll do one more this is from
Tina now my glasses are getting fogged
up for my fake tears from Tina says very
disappointed in your presentation
related to the gifts of the Holy Spirit
I would have thought you would have done
a better job with that in particular in
the way of understanding the dynamics of
those gifts and the use of them
especially in the modern church today
yes it is a gift that is given to only
particular people and just like any gift
that's given to you or me we can't abuse
that gift I would highly encourage you
that when you do any kind of commentary
on something this specific in regard to
the spirituality of those in the
Catholic Church that you give it due
respect and do research mockery does not
serve you well I was very offended
personally by your Cavalier approach to
a very important topic and a very
important part of the spirituality of
many faithful Catholics like myself
she's referring I believe to when we
talked about speaking in tongues and I
said that people who babble in gibberish
are not really speaking in tongues and
that is not a gift of the you know
speaking gibberish is not a gift of the
Holy Spirit it is just theatrical
embarrassing nonsense and I wish the
Christians wouldn't do that so she says
that she's offended
that well Tina I I never objected to the
concept of holy spirit of the holy
spirit giving gifts I agree that that
happens we all have gifts from the Holy
Spirit
in one form or another but the question
is whether babbling in gibberish is a
gift from the Holy Spirit or if it's
just a man-made thing and something that
people do because it's a trend in modern
Christianity and I emphasize a modern
trend
nobody was babbling in gibberish in the
church prior to the 19th century or so
so that's really the questions is
gibberish a gift of the Holy Spirit
now when you babble gibberish and nobody
can understand you and nobody on earth
recognizes it as a language am I
supposed to take your word for it that
it's some kind of mysterious angelic
language that no one can understand like
when my when my son starts babbling
gibberish and says I I made up a new
language daddy am I supposed to take
that seriously as an actual real
language well you know I I guess I I
don't to be honest with you I guess and
I don't mean this in an offensive way
but I just don't see any reason to
believe that your gibberish is really
some kind of miraculous event and not
just gibberish sounds like gibberish
looks like gibberish according to
everyone around us it's Jim no one
understands I mean it you know it seems
by all accounts to be gibberish so I'm
gonna go with gibberish there simply is
no reason to believe anything other than
that and considering how detrimental
this stuff is to the church and how it
serves no functional purpose whatsoever
unlike when the early disciples did it
and they were doing it so that other
people could understand them so that
they could evangelize to those people
but this does not serve that purpose it
doesn't really seem to seem to serve any
purpose other than to embarrass
Christians so I'm led even more to the
conclusion that there's no reason to
believe it's miraculous do you really
think that God is evangelizing God is
drawing people to himself by inspiring
Christians to babble nonsensically it's
I almost is like blasphemous that you're
gonna you know babble nonsensical even
blame it on the
holy spirit I mean of all the miracles
that God can perform you think you think
making people babble is a miracle well I
don't honestly and I'm not gonna believe
you just because you say it and again no
offense there but like if you told me
you had the ability to heal the blind
now that's a real miracle that and maybe
there are people in the world today who
can heal blind people I'm not gonna say
that they don't exist but I'm not gonna
take your word for it if you come up to
me say yeah I can heal blind people I'm
not gonna say oh oh my gosh you can Wow
okay well I totally believe you and see
my reluctance in believing you is not a
reluctance in trusting God is that this
isn't about God it's about you I'm just
not I'm not gonna implicitly trust what
you tell me because you're a person
you're not God right so from you I'm
gonna need more evidence I'm not just
gonna believe it because you say it and
so if you say you can perform that kind
of miracle you can heal the blind I'm
gonna say okay show me let me see let me
see you do it bring a blind person in
here and let me see you heal them but if
you can't do it or if you heal a blind
person but by all appearances they're
still blind and they can't see at the
end of it then I'm gonna say that no you
don't really have that gift
you're either confused or you're a
charlatan lying you know it seems to be
the two options I'm not accusing you of
lying but I think that people can by the
power of suggestion come to sincerely
believe that they're in the midst of a
divine trance when really it's just an
ecstatic kind of hysterical but totally
earthbound phenomenon I gave the example
of hypnosis that's a good parallel I
think people really believe that they
are hypnotized you watch a hidden
hypnotist on TV and you see people go up
there I'm gonna ring the bell you're
gonna bark like a dog
and then they ring the bell he barks
like a dog they're not he's not really
hypnotized nothing has happened there
other than he's been convinced to play
along without realizing that he's
playing along and that's what I think
the gibberish is I'm afraid to say so
once again
the issue is that nobody has provided me
one single substantive reason to believe
that gibberish is a miracle and you
insisting on it and saying that you're
offended is not a reason and and that's
just it it and and quoting the Bible and
say well it says here in the Bible it
yeah I know it says that but that
doesn't prove that that's what you're
doing the Bible recounts many miracles
but that doesn't mean that you can do it
and if you say you can again I'm gonna
need evidence I'm not just gonna believe
you
and I think that's the approach that we
all should have and that's the other
thing as Christians we don't want I
think we undermine our faith when we
appear to be gullible like if it seems
that we'll just believe anything anyone
tells us then you know what people on
the outside they're gonna start to think
they're gonna say oh well so is maybe
their whole religion is just that it
seems like this is a gullible person
just believe anything so that's I guess
that's all the Bible is just another
story that this gullible person believed
because they believe everything now I
think we want to show some discernment
and show that no we do have some
standards here and we're not gonna fall
for any story someone tells us all right
so that's that I guess we'll leave it
there I hope you guys have a great not
just a great weekend but a great Easter
weekend the most important weekend of
the year for for Christians everywhere
so god bless and Godspeed today on the
Ben Shapiro show we recap the Muller
report Democrats call for impeachment
and the media changed their June from
collusion to obstruction that's today on
the bench Shapiro show